i want to talk now about
police reform in ohio
there have been some things that we have
been able to do
by executive action
on june 17th of last year
i ordered every cabinet agency
to review the use of forced policies
and also to ban the use of
chokeholds that has been done
so every department under my direct
jurisdiction
highway patrol ohio department of
natural resources
and others have now banned the use of
chokeholds
last summer i ordered the highway troll
to start the action to obtain body
cameras
for everyone for some time they have had
dash cameras but i felt it was
appropriate now
for them to lead by example
and to have the body cameras
the purchasing of these body cameras has
begun
and we would anticipate within a short
period of time
the members of the highway patrol will
always have
on the body cameras
next we established the office of law
enforcement recruiting
within the office of criminal justice
services
again to help local law enforcement in
this area
next i ordered the ohio community police
collaborative
to develop a standard for law
enforcement responses to mass protests
i'm happy to say that they have now
adopted a uniform
standard let me talk
for a moment about several budget
initiatives
that are now in front of the general
assembly
several things that are pertinent were
contained in our budget
we had 10 million dollars we provided
for law enforcement body cameras
for local law enforcement around
the state of ohio in addition to that
we provide in our budget a million
dollars in grant funding to support
local police agencies
and innovative initiatives recruitment
and minorities these are two things
that are contained in our budget let me
now turn
to legislative proposals i talked this
morning
with state representative phil plummer
phil is a former sheriff of montgomery
county
he's been working on a law enforcement
reform package
we have worked with him on this i'm
happy to say that he advises me that
this bill will now be ready to be
introduced within the next
few days this bill will increase
accountability and transparency in law
enforcement
it was developed with the health of the
ohio attorney general's office
of veteran law enforcement officers
organizations including the ohio
association of chiefs of police and the
buckeye state
sheriff's association
as well as civil rights leaders
this bill will do a number of things
let me just mention several we'll
establish a police
a peace officer oversight board
it is time that in ohio we begin to
treat law enforcement as the
professionals that they
are what does that mean
it means that in other professions if
your doctor
your nurse your lawyer we could go on
and on
there's state knowledge state
regulations there's a state board
there's a state disciplinary board a
state board that has the ability to pull
a license
to suspend a license it's time we do
that
in the area of law enforcement again it
is a profession
we should treat it as such
next the bill also establishes a use of
force
database a statewide
use of force database so that
the almost a thousand law enforcement
agencies in the state of ohio would
report
use of force and that would be contained
in one
central uh location whenever the use of
force
was used next it would establish an
officer discipline database an officer
disciplined database and again this goes
back
to treating law enforcement as the
profession
that it is so situation we have now
someone can go from one police
department to another and
if they left under bad terms and
that officer doesn't even report that he
worked at the other law enforcement
agency and it's clear across the state
one law enforcement agency may have no
idea
that he worked for another law
enforcement agency again
an officer discipline database
fourth will require an independent
investigation of officer-involved
critical
incidents again outside for
outside impartial coming in i think
we'll give people more
confidence in in the end results
i think there's also a general agreement
that we need more police training i've
never met a police officer who did not
think that
more training was was good
we need an independent sustainable
funding source
for law enforcement training in ohio
last month as part of
the need to address law enforcement
training in the state i asked
the justice of criminal justice services
to senate a survey to law enforcement
agencies all throughout the state of
ohio
and we asked them to identify training
needs and the type of training
that they actually have conducted in the
last year
aspirationally what they want but also
what have they done the survey is back
on the 30th this month
the information from this survey is
going to be used to assist in studying
the potential for developing a long-term
funding solution
for law enforcement training in ohio i
know talking with phil plummer this
morning
i've not looked at the language but he
tells me that there is there's language
and money
in the bill that he has introduced
in regard to law enforcement training
once we have established an independent
funding source
we need to mandate minimum continuing
professional education
training hours just as we do in other in
other professions
certainly that should always include
de-escalation and use of force
training
fran i had the opportunity this morning
to visit primary one health vaccination
site at state
state stephen's uh community house in
columbus
we just i just say at state saint
stephen's they do some amazing work
helping everyone from young young
children
all the way up uh to senior citizens and
they've done that
for over a hundred years uh primary one
health a community health center
operates
for clinton around the city and they go
giving back nations in from one clinic
to another uh primary one health
like other health centers and providers
are receiving state vaccine allocations
every week
uh let me commend primary one their team
i had the opportunity to meet friend i
did several
number of their members of their team
today
and others like them are working hard to
ensure their efforts are focused on
delivering vaccine
to everyone and certainly including
communities of color fran i talked to
uh one man i just just it's always
interesting what you find
uh and what you hear when you talk to
people and ask them why are you getting
vaccinated i always say you know did you
have a
hesitancy about getting vaccinated and
there's always a story
about you know how they got there and
why they are there
and one man told us he said i've got 86
year old
mother and she's already received her
vaccine
and i take care of her um i want to make
sure she's around for a long time
and i felt i needed to get the vaccine
so everyone's got a story
and so many people are getting the
vaccine and getting that
get for others um clinic at st
stevens is just here when you talk to
people
and ask them why are you getting
vaccinated i always say you know did you
have a
hesitancy by getting vaccinated and
there's always a story
um about you know how they got there and
why they are there
and one man told us he said i've got a
86 year old
mother and she's already received her
vaccine
and i take care of her i want to make
sure she's around
for a long time and i felt i needed to
get
the vaccine so everyone's got a story
and so many people are getting the
vaccine
and getting that it for others
clinic at st stephens is just a great
example i think of efforts across ohio
to ensure that all ohioans all ohioans
have
access to this very precious and
life-saving vaccine
april is minority health month every day
our team is focused
in our local health department partners
and non-profits throughout the state and
so many others are focusing on making
sure vaccines
are delivered fairly to minority
communities underserved communities
we still have much to do to make sure
all ohioans are
reached and it's convenient and easy for
every ohioan to get it
but i just want to again commend the
work that primary one is doing
and other health clinics like them
across the state
tomorrow is earth day it's also our
grandson grady's birthday
we plan on friend i just for talking on
the phone a minute ago
i plan on planting uh grady always
plants a tree and um you know deciding
what kind of
tree and talk with grady tonight about
what kind of tree we'll we'll plant
tomorrow
so planetary in honor of gradient honor
of earth day
it really earth day is a great
opportunity to recognize what each one
of us can do
to protect the earth protect our planet
one of the things that we can do is help
clean up litter litters
it's ugly and it costs a lot uh so i
asked the ohio department of natural
resources the ohio department of
transportation
the higher general environmental
protection agency to launch a campaign
to focus on how a little bit of litter
contributes to the bigger statewide
problem
this new campaign will prioritize
sharing information about litter why
it's a problem
and what we can each do to stop uh from
adding to this litter problem
additionally
our agencies will host various events
throughout the spring
and the summer including a litter summit
today the ohio department of
transportation director jack marshbanks
is at the odot
hillyard garage with the city of
columbus director of public
service jennifer gallagher this week
they challenge their respective staffs
to a friendly competition
of who can collect the most of garbage
so let me go to them now uh director
marsh banks how are you
governor i am fine thank you for your
leadership in these trying times
and yes we are having our step up pick
up litter challenge with the city of
columbus we have
public service director jennifer
gallagher with us this afternoon i would
also like to introduce
our ohio epa director lori stevenson
yes laurie's here and our uh ohio
department of natural resources director
mary merce who knows all about trees
she's here also so i wanted to share
with everyone that
we are working together cabinet-wide to
make sure
that we are making ohio as beautiful as
it can be
one of the most annoying and unfortunate
things we have to do at odot
is pick up the trash of other people
along our roadways it might seem like
it's just a little bit of litter to you
when you toss it out of your
car but it's a big problem last year
alone
oda picked up 600 and probably 362
000 bags of trash with our crews
our adopted highway volunteers and
inmates in franklin county alone
we picked up over 29 000 uh
bags of trash and these trucks behind us
that's 100
bags of trash in the odot uh truck and
that's what we pick up in one day
so we are asking people to do their part
dispose of your trash in the proper
place not on our road size roadsides
and equally important make sure if
you're carrying a load down our highways
that it's tied down
and if you're carrying something even
larger put a tarp over it
together we can demonstrate pride of
place as ohioans
and we're working together and we thank
everyone out there listening to
uh for helping us and making litter a
blight of the past
i'd like to introduce right now governor
our city of columbus public service
director jennifer gallagher will tell
you some more about
the challenge jennifer director
gallagher thank you very much for
joining us
thank you for what you do good afternoon
governor dewine thank you for inviting
me to be here today
on the eve of earth day i think you know
that the city of columbus and the ohio
department of transportation
are engaged in a friendly competition to
see whose crews collect the most to
litter
along our roadways we are battling it up
in a step up and pick up litter
challenge
during this week of earth day to clean
up our communities
mayor gather and director march banks
have had clean
fun engaging in a litter a little trash
talk during this challenge
but there really is nothing funny about
the serious problem of litter
this unsightly and unacceptable
pollution
strong along our roadsides and elsewhere
denigrates our community and causes
damaging environmental impacts
often litter is a great problem in our
neighborhoods that are already
challenged in socioeconomic factors
on this day before earth day in 2021
columbus continues to move closer to
being an equitable and sustainable city
my department of public service leads
our city's aggressive litter abasement
efforts
last year we completed our first ever
litter index to score and catalog
the amount of litter on columbus streets
this will help us prioritize
cleanup and enforcement our department
cleans up illegally dumped
trash and debris in city alleys and
litter along state highways and city
arterial streets
we also work with the franklin county
municipal court
to use litter collection as an
alternative sentence when appropriate
even though we are opponents in the step
up and pick up challenge
columbus does assist odot with litter
cleanup along freeways and ramps when
needed
in the near future mayor ginther and i
will be announcing a major initiative
that will employ hundreds of columbus
teens and young adults to collect
litter and participate in hands-on
environmental educational activities
inspiring them to become leaders in
protecting our precious environment
even before our competition with odot
began on monday
columbus street maintenance crews had
cleaned up more than 26 tons
yes 26 tons of litter and almost
200 tires discarded along our city
roadways
it is a messy task that also poses
safety risks for our crews
it is a task that shouldn't be necessary
as director march banks mentioned
litter is a solvable problem when each
of us takes the time and personal
responsibility
to properly dispose of our trash use
public trash receptacles
or wait until you get home to toss your
trash in our refuse container and
recyclables in your cart
get involved in community cleanups our
city has a very
active keep columbus beautiful program
countless volunteers
devote thousands of hours each year to
litter collection in neighborhoods
throughout our community
just join the effort challenge a
neighboring subdivision to see who can
collect the most litter to build pride
and friendships
similar to the competition this week
between us and odi
now governor odot is a worthy opponent
with all due respect to governor
director march face and his team when
the final tally is announced tomorrow on
earth day
of how much litter each of our crews has
collected this week
i do think that the city is going to
walk away with the bragging rights
thank you for hosting me here today i so
appreciate it
professor gallagher thank you very much
and to all uh
all four directors we we appreciate it
and
keep picking up the trash and we'll see
who wins
odot will be victoria's goal
thank you appreciate it thanks thanks
everybody
eric let's go to the slides for the data
we'll start first with the
daily data cases 1789
um the good news is we're seeing what
appears to be certainly a plateau
in cases we will feel better when it's
really a defined
downward direction uh we i don't think
we can say we're there yet
but we certainly hope as more and more
people get vaccinated we're crowding
this vaccine
we're crowding this virus out making it
tough for this virus to spread so
it's still at a high rate um and but
it's
certainly not going up and um we're
seeing some
certainly a very significant leveling
off if we look at the other numbers
unfortunately our hospitalizations are
higher than they than they have been
on the average icu is is right what the
21 day average
let's go to an excellent area we look at
this this is all 88 counties again this
is the key indicator
or top county unfortunately remains
lucas county
at 357 cases per
per hundred thousand over a two week
period of time so lucas williams madison
erie summit cuyahoga jefferson defiance
ash tubular
uh those are the top unfortunately the
top counties
in lowest county uh is galia and meigs
and fayette
so again as we look at this
again we would hope that this would all
become quite
um we're still at a high pretty high
level
as you can see three and a half times
what the cdc says is high incident level
and you know this is appearing certainly
more prominently in
in the northern part of the state
again this is the top top counties and
we'll go to the next one eric
our daily slide now this is our daily
slide of vaccine
first thing i look at comes out usually
around midday and
you know certainly keeping an eye on
that
these are first doses 29 000. uh so
not where we certainly where we want to
be not where we have been
um you know we had days that were 80 and
90 000.
and we've seen certainly a significant
decline in the number of first doses
i want to look at the
at the age groups and i think the age
groups are quite
quite interesting because
our older ohioans those numbers continue
to
to slowly go up even though they're
already at a fairly high rate
over 80 is 70 almost 74 and a half
percent
75 to 79 is 75 and a half percent
uh 70 to 74 is 78
of that population has got the vaccine
and 65 to 69 is 72
uh and we drop off you know from from
from there
one of the keys going forward obviously
is to get
people 50 and under um
taking it at a at a higher rate than
what we're seeing
uh so far an interesting uh
if you look at the first doses i asked
our team to break it out
for just 16 and 17 year olds
and not bad almost almost a fifth of all
them them 18.6 percent
of 16 and 17 year olds have now received
their first dose
um so you know that's what happens with
our younger people is really going to
determine
you know how fast we can reach this herd
immunity how fast we can reach the
numbers that we
need to reach um to make it a lot
lot safer second dose
eric you'll put that slide up and again
you know 60 66 000
first second doses uh yesterday
uh so those numbers are hanging in there
pretty
pretty good on this on the second doses
um
we are now at 38 going back to the first
doses 38 percent of the
population the total population of the
state and some people obviously are not
even eligible
uh 38 of the total population of state
has got the first dose
and 27.5 uh his are now
are now fully fully vaccinated
eric we'll go to the hospitalization
slides
again these are lagging indicators
uh 1243 is the is the number
four for today
so as we look at the virus where are we
today in ohio
in regard to our battle
these are really the essential facts 38
of us uh more than 4.4 million of us
have now received our first shot that's
good
um second cases while high
seem seem to have plateaued that's good
third though is not good and that is the
virus is more contagious
than it's ever been some estimates are
40
more contagious the way dr vanderhoff
explains it is it's
it sticks better um
so the first two facts are good third
fact is is not good
uh so dr vanderhoff let's go to you and
maybe kind of
from from a medical point of view and a
health point of view
um maybe talk a little bit about we
we're kind of
settling out into two different groups
uh and they're not
certainly not permanent groups we're
having more people vaccinate every day
but we have a significant number of us
almost 40 percent now
of us who are vaccinated and we
obviously have people who are who are
not
vaccinated some are not even eligible
yet but
talk to us a little bit about the risk
of where each each group might might be
and how we should think about this as we
move forward now individuals can think
about it
well thank you governor as you note
the pandemic is quickly evolving into
a tale of two groups of ohioans
on the one hand we have the vaccinated
ohioans who
are very well protected against this
virus and
much less likely to spread it to other
people their situation
is very good but that very
good situation for the vaccinated
contrasts
sharply with that for the unvaccinated
unvaccinated ohioans simply lack the
same protection
against the virus which is now as you
noted
more contagious and able to put younger
people
at much greater risk including the risk
of ending up in the hospital
also as you noted essentially the new
variants have evolved
to stick more easily to our cells
so it takes less of the virus less
exposure
to make a person sick you add to that
the fact that more older ohioans and you
reviewed those numbers
have been vaccinated and it all means
that if you're young and unvaccinated
what might not have been much of a
concern to you this fall
sure ought to be a concern right now
and if you're counting on herd immunity
to
cover you you really can't count on it
yet
there's no doubt our herd our population
is more and more protected as a result
of vaccines